When you declare a variable, it's important that you give it an initial value.
Look at this variable. It's name is rocketSpeed. It's type is called double.
And I'll talk about what double means in just a minute. What I want to show you
first is over here, the last part of the variable declaration. And that's the
initial value. And it really is important that you always supply an initial
value when you declare a variable. Because if you forget, and later use the
rocketSpeed variable, that would be an error. Every variable that you used must
really have a value. The best time to set the value is right when you declare
it. Now, back to the curious type double. That means it's a number that can
have a decimal point, such as here, 24,724.573. So, when you see the word
double, you should simply think a number with a decimal point. And ignore the
curious name. Now, look at this variable declaration. The name is
sallyRidesBirthday, the type is the Day class, and the initial value looks like
this. You will see soon exactly what this syntax means, but when you look at
it, it seems intuitively clear, we make a new Day object with a date 1951, May
26.